awfully tragically it was just over two
weeks ago we were talking about another
mass shooting the Covenant School
shooting in Nashville that attack led to
protests at the State House demanding
new gun laws and two black lawmakers
were expelled by the Republican majority
for participating now one of those state
representatives Justin Jones has been
reappointed to a seat by the Nashville
Metro Council but to push for changes in
gun laws Remains the backdrop Mark
Strassman has more from Nashville
Justin Jones has been elected as the
interim successor for the vacancy of
Tennessee house district 52.
to Cheers in the gallery the Nashville
Metro Council stood with Justin Jones
and returned him to the Tennessee House
of Representatives we all saw the video
of what he did last week the mostly
white Republican caucus in the Tennessee
house flexed its super majority power to
the people expelling the two young black
lawmakers from mocking decorum with a
bullhorn and bravado they did in the
chamber with other members
break every rule that we almost have
yesterday Jones marched with hundreds on
the state capitol telling Tennessee's
Republican leadership their efforts have
backfired my message to Cameron Sexton
is that your attack on Democracy thank
you because it's galvanized a nationwide
movement
foreign
the cheers followed Jones onto the floor
of the very chamber who is expelled from
just days before there comes a time
where time itself is ready for a change
that time has come back here in
Nashville Tennessee the future of Justin
Pearson's seat hangs in the balance the
Shelby County Board of Commissioners is
expected to decide tomorrow whether to
return the former Memphis representative
to his now vacant seat on an interim
basis we are here because our people our
communities are saying it is time for
justice now I caught up with Pearson
outside Nashville city hall why is it
important for them to appoint you not
for you but as a message exactly it is
important that we send a clear message
that the people in District 86
representation matters and that this
illegitimate disenfranchisement of their
vote and of their choice is wrong
so tomorrow in Memphis the Shelby County
Commissioner will decide whether to
appoint Pearson to his old seat and in
case you're wondering lawmakers cannot
be expelled twice here for the same
offense
Gail
I was actually wondering that Mark
Strassman thank you very much